the newest supreme court justice amy  coney barrett was confirmed  yesterday yeah now the white house was  being very secretive about the  swearing-in ceremony  but get this we actually actually  somehow don't ask me how  got a hold of some of the footage of  that ceremony  take a look judge amy coney barrett has  now officially been confirmed by the u.s  senate  let's go live to the swearing-in  ceremony  thank you sean as you can see most  members of the trump administration are  in attendance today  and here you can see the honorable amy  coney barrett as she steps forward to  begin the swearing-in  ceremony president trump of course also  here to say some words in support of her  appointment  as is judge clarence thomas who we see  now beginning preparations for the  swearing-in  and here she is ladies and gentlemen  your newest appointee to the supreme  court  associate justice amy coney barrett